so i go into this audition and i'm
reading the scene with jeff goldblum
and i it's my first audition ever in my
life
and he's playing my dad and then at one
point
he just stood up and stood over me
because i'm like this rebellious teen
and he stood over me like a dad would do
and he's also a very large
tall man yeah and he's so in the moment
and
when he stood up it was like
nobody else was in the room it was him
and i having a
full-on full-on argument about what i
will and will not do
and i'm not having it and it
i just i just was so in the moment
living moment to moment listening
hearing playing off of him
and we were done and the scene was over
i
left that building it was over on warner
brothers it was actually
on the lot at warner brothers and i'm
walking between warehouses
and i say to myself this
is what i'm meant to do i don't care if
i get this part
that was the most amazing experience i
was doing exactly
what i've been training to do wow i can
do this this is my destiny what if it
was a shitty audition would you felt the
same way
i don't care i don't know because that's
not what happened that's not what i see
that's how my mind works
i always think okay you were great last
night but you're gonna suck tomorrow
that's unfortunately how my mind works
like you're never
gonna it's never enough it's never
freaking enough but that in that moment
you're young
you're ambitious you have this wonderful
encounter with goldblum this great
audition
and you felt like this is what i want to
do for the rest of my life 100
and you know i think where you're what
you're talking about is
is true i think two things i'm sorry
that that's how
where your brain goes to and i really
hope that changes soon i'm working on it
because you do deserve that and then
second of all i think
what is interesting about that is there
is a difference
between the way i was
back in the day when you're really young
and your whole life is in front of you
and you just feel like the stakes don't
matter you don't have a mortgage you
don't have a house you don't have a kid
you don't have college around the corner
like nothing's it it's like on to the
next i feel like to hollywood like you
have more auditions like i would
audition 900 times a week so it's like
who cares if i didn't get that part i'll
get the next one you know
it just but now when you get older the
auditions come fewer and far between
and the stakes are higher and you know
the the actual the actual projects
are better quality so you're meeting
with higher end people
and prestigious projects and and these
people that you
really want to impress right so
yeah you know i totally have those
moments you just don't want to [ __ ] the
bed
you can avoid [ __ ] the bag i have
[ __ ] the bed before
i mean i have to have really painfully
oh yeah yeah
and done that and just been like oh my
god i mean do you get
do you do you have it now or did you
have any sort of anxiety before
auditions then or were you
it sounds like you're a free spirit you
were sort of just going forward
every week all these auditions but now
do you think things have changed or
you're like oh my gosh
everything's on this i got to be great
i'm getting anxiety yeah the anxiety
came
later it always does doesn't it why
after you've had some success you think
okay why is my anxiety still here it
should be gone because i've dealt with
all this stuff
i'm used to it but you never get used to
it no i think that's a great question
asked my therapist but i have an
inkling of an idea and i think it stakes
it's also if you feel safe on a set
or in in a scene with somebody like if
they're not a safe person
it's very hard for you if you don't have
chemistry or a genuine
um need to my dog wants to be on the lap
without perfectly fine
this is cristiano ronaldo oh my gosh
cristiano
um hi very cute um
so i think there's how safe you feel
and then i also think um
i don't know i i just think it's a
a myriad of different possibilities yeah
i think you know
definitely especially on set when you
feel safe and you see
feel like everybody's got your back when
you feel like the other actor is
listening and he's there for you and he
wants
you to be your best there's something
really nice about that
and uh but we also have to
be able to push through when say like i
remember
reading a long time ago and this has
always stayed with me and was
in some like you know apocalyptic type
movie
where like a volcano is going off and
like it's a very integral
scene and they have to get it in one
shot and you're in a scene with harrison
ford
you know it was like some like massive
six days seven nights
six days seven nights or something maybe
it was and you know like
the pressure is on to get it in one take
yeah um you have to also be reliable
you know and professional enough to
overcome your anxiety
and you know i'm just basically trying
to avoid those situations
yeah you know what's crazy is like you
were we always have odd jobs like i
could tell you i worked at a grocery
store for years i could tell you that i
worked at a pet land discounts uh
cleaning chinchilla [ __ ] at six a.m i
could tell you that i worked at a
go-kart track as a mechanic and a
roller rink dj and all these things but
like you know
you you've done some odd jobs i mean now
you waited tables but you worked
you worked i guess in real estate right
i was a i worked
i was a leasing agent at a at a place
but that was my least interesting job i
think my best job was i was an aerobics
instructor and i worked at a video store
and then i think uh do they still have
aerobics instructors can you call them
that do you ever hear
oh you guys want to take aerobics next
tuesday no i don't think they have that
position anymore it was at a family
fitness
back in the 90s uh or
late 80s it would have been and then um
and then what was oh i i actually i know
i
i am a waitress but what makes it
interesting about when i was at waitress
was that it was at my parents restaurant
and my dad fired me
like you know you're bad when your dad
fired why did he fire you
because he hadn't i wasn't wasn't
trustworthy enough to work the dinner
um so i worked the lunch shift and i had
a table of eight people and a big ass
tray
with all the food that my um my dad was
in the kitchen at that
for the lunch hour i guess the chef had
called in or whatever and so he was
doing it
he loaded up the tray i picked up the
tray and they went through the kitchen
door which
you know swings and just as i was
walking out the swinging door
tipped the back of my tray because it
was that big and it was just enough
for me to just lose my my positioning
of the tray and everything went on the
floor crash and my dad looked up and he
goes you're fired
he said you're fired on the spot